a $10,000 reward is being offered for
information on the mysterious
disappearance of a government scientist
Timothy Cunningham is an epidemiologist
at the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention in Atlanta Georgia
he disappeared more than two weeks ago
after he left work early saying he felt
sick Omar Villafranca sneer Cunningham's
home in Atlanta with more on this
mystery Omar good morning good morning
Timothy Cunningham is a disease
detective with the CDC deploying to
Public Health hotspots to investigate
viruses like Zika or Ebola but no one
has heard from him or seen him since
February 12th and now this community is
rallying to make sure the man himself is
not in danger investigators return to
the woods around Timothy Cunningham's
house Monday searching for more clues
I'm not sure what else we can do his
family found his wallet his car even his
beloved dog all left behind in his
Atlanta home Timothy has been
unaccounted for since the 12th
Cunningham's father Terrell drove from
Maryland to Georgia after not hearing
from his son for two days his parents
and other family members have been
putting up missing posters throughout
Cunningham's neighborhood and they're
trying to get the word out about his
disappearance through the media
he has such a history of being so
responsible and dependable that that I
think that is what puts us all and as
such disbelief
Cunningham graduated from Morehouse
College and earned advanced degrees from
Harvard the 35 year old CDC scientist
reportedly lived alone his next door
neighbor
viviana Tory says Cunningham said
something odd to her husband the day he
disappeared he told my husband to tell
his wife me to raise the cell phone
number for my cell phone police do not
suspect foul play but they also say
they're exploring all possibilities
Cunningham's family is pleading for the
public's help if anyone sees anything
that relates to or think you have seen
Timothy please call the number the CDC
released a statement I want to
they said dr. Cunningham's colleagues
and friends at the CDC hope that he is
safe we want him to return to his loved
ones and his work protecting people's
health Nora
Omar thank you that is quite a mystery I
hope they find him I do too it's such a
cryptic message it seems to indicate he
knew he was leaving whether it was on
his own or not is a question very scary
story for his family yeah we'll follow
up on it